un moment donné j'ai eu l'occasion
d'acheter un appart ça vient d'être fait
là
je suis dans le 9 2
il y a les gens du 9 3 qui vont siffler
mais c'est pas très loin
vous ne serez pas étonné coûte cher
quand vous fasse une interview dernier
coup
[Musique]
dernier coup de tête
dernier coup de tête dans mon dernier
match de football je sais pas quand tu
as quand ça remonte parce que j'ai une
sciatique en ce moment donc ça fait un
moment que j'ai toujours au ballon
dernier coup de cœur
un petit coup de coeur pour ma femme
actuelle avec qui je viens d'avoir un
enfant la sciatique dont tu parlais ça
vient de là aussi dernier coup de poing
ça doit être en même temps que le coup
de tête dernier coup de folie
j'ai vécu 37 ans à Saint-Denis si tu
veux donc voilà un moment donné j'ai eu
l'occasion d'acheter un appart ça vient
d'être fait là
je suis dans le 9 2
il y a les gens du 9 3 qui vont siffler
mais c'est pas très loin
et après Versailles après je sais pas
peut-être dernier coup de foudre
je te l'ai dit tout à l'heure le flash
c'est ma femme
dernier coup de gueule
dernier coup de gueule je crois que
c'est écrit dans c'est mal barré
tout à l'heure de mes potes là dans la
loge pour lui dire je passais à ton
émission qu'est-ce qu'il y en a à fond
ils s'en bat les couilles
on n'a pas l'occasion de passer souvent
à la télé donc ça leur fait plaisir
quand on est là dernier coup de soleil
la dernière fois que je suis allé en
vacances tu as vu mon temps il est pas
très bronzé donc moi dès que je vois un
rayon de soleil
il y a plus de soleil dans le 9 2 que
dans le 23 ça dépend de l'altitude à
laquelle tu habites dernier coup de bol
eh coup de bol je suis rentré deuxième
la au top ça fait peut-être un petit
coup de balle dernier coup de blues
il y a pas longtemps non plus malgré la
sciatique on se débrouille et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu